[Music]
okay
good opponent now um let's go with the
sicilian
and c3 sicilian by not a rapper c3
sicilian so
we already know that there are two main
responses to the c3 sicilian
um there's knight f6 but the move that
yeah there's knight f6 and there's d5
striking in the center immediately let's
go d5
striking in the center immediately
and now the battle begins to revolve
around
this d4 pawn the question is can black
apply
a significant amount of pressure on that
d4 pawn so how do we apply
how do we continue applying pressure on
that d4 pawn like what do we do
yeah knight c6 all very simple i talked
about this with charlie today
and now bishop g4 bishop comes out
applying indirect pressure to the pawn
because we
are pressuring the knight and now we
need to get these pieces out so we go e6
and then we're gonna go knight f6 i mean
this is all super
normal stuff bishop drops back to h5
one sec
okay and now c4 by
not a wrapper okay so c4 attacks the
queen
we have to move this queen back where
should we move it
i mean is there any particular reason
to move it to one square as opposed to
another square
yeah so uh the d7 square is pretty good
so if we go queen e4 first of all then
that walks right into knight c3
the good move i think is queen to d7
because at least we keep the queen
deployed so it defends all these squares
but now we have to be very careful about
what we do if we take on d5
and then we move our knight away white
can leap into e5 with knight e5 white
gets a very big initiative so here
we must find a better square for the
knight but it seems that no better
square exists because this knight covers
the d4 square but what can we do in
order to guarantee that square for the
knight
we can actually take on f3 first
intermediate move
then this knight gets a very nice
central square on d4 that's a key move
actually without it
uh without this move black is already
busted i'm not sure if this is theory or
maybe i did something wrong already
i mean this looks reasonable for black
let's see how he responds
okay knight c3 i mean we need to keep
developing our pieces knight knight f6
this is pretty standard bishop e3 yeah
this guy is clearly
incredibly strong um okay
so he wants to take on on d4
can we support this knight somehow
well if we take the bishop then we let
his queen get it get open and
our position becomes super cramped so
there's a move here which allows us yes
e5 is correct i think
e5 is a key move and then you might
notice this pawn and say well isn't this
pawn
a problem well it is but it's not as big
of a problem as people might think it is
because
we can blockade it with our bishop we
can put our bishop on d6 this pawn is
immobilized
and uh that pawn might have a
counterpart on d4 should he take the
knight
now we can finally castle our king and
we don't have to worry about the king
safety anymore let's see what
not a rapper plays here yeah we're going
to castle short i mean
make you min rating with a party 51
thank you so much man appreciate it i'm
doing just one or two games of the speed
run
and then i will wrap up myself because i
am pretty exhausted thank you sullen
nader for the prime
okay so now we can castle now we can
castle and let's see how white
plays this position um
now how can black play this position
what are our
various plans well we see that this is a
pawn chain
and when we have a pawn chain we need to
start thinking about undermining the
base of the pawn chain so the move b5
comes to mind
it turns out that b5 is a blunder
because remember his bishop is making
contact with the knight
and that knight is guarding b5 so if we
play b5 immediately
and he's going to take the knight and
then he's going to take the pawn on b5
but
i like the idea of preparing b5 by
playing a6
i like that move quite a bit actually a6
preparing b5 attacking the base of the
pawn chain
that's not necessarily what i would have
played myself
um but it's a perfectly sensible
idea there's several ways you can play
this position with black
uh attacking the base of the pawn chain
is very thematic it's what we discussed
yeah this is the reason why
i was going to play h6 because now he's
threatening to take on f6
and we'll ruin our pawn structure in
front of our king that is unthinkable
what can we do about this and this move
that we're about to play
is a move that a lot of people hesitate
or really struggle to play because it's
a retreating move
but and i've sort of made this point
throughout
you should never be afraid to make
retreating moves because they are
retreating moves that should not be a
reason to not play a move the move is 98
if we play bishop b7 guys
we drop the pawn on e5 be very careful
when you do make a retreating move you
need to think about
which pawns or pieces or squares have
been left behind
are you leaving anything undefended
maybe got to be careful about that
make sure that you're bearing that in
mind 98 doesn't leave anything
undefended then i wasn't defending
anything
94. okay so that's a good move
but again his activity here is not
really as
good as it appears again we can make
another
we can make another retreating move
right we don't want to give away this
bishop this bishop is like
atlas holding the world on its shoulders
so let's just drop the bishop to e7
and the secondary idea of this move you
guys see this knight on ea where can
it eventually go what is the ideal place
for this
for this night we've already
discussed the notion that the knight is
the best blockader
so this night uh the bishop clears out
the parking space for the night
and in order to put the knight on d6 we
would first potentially maybe have to
move the knight away from e4 although we
don't really have to we can play knight
d6 immediately
and now we're in very good shape this
night is as they say in russian and
eternal night
that knight is completely unassailable
his bishop is biting on its own
granite and uh you could see that
white's activity is
uh purely illusory thank you for for the
prime
yeah so g3 now we have a very
well let me think
okay so we have a pretty elementary way
of getting rid of this knight who can
tell me
how can we do that how can we get rid of
the knight
bingo yeah good job f5
the knight must move then i must move
and then we block gate on d6 and our
position reaches
epic purple i mean we have an ideal
position in that
case and then we can start attacking on
the king's side because our pieces are
perfectly placed
perfectly situated and then we can start
pressuring him in the center we can
bring more pieces into the game it
really depends on
how how white plays but uh
that looks absolutely horrible for white
thank you for the prime alacius
ii thank you thank you okay so d6 i saw
this is the last big obstacle that we
have to surmount and
this is where i mentioned this earlier
at this 2300 level
there are moments when the game
literally just
devolves into pure tactics pure tactics
and this is one of those moments there
is no inherent logic
for why the correct move is the correct
move does anybody see what the correct
move is we can win a piece here
if black plays super precisely so we
don't play knight takes d6
then knight takes c5 and the game is
unclear okay i have to make a move
knight takes f3 check and after queen
takes f3 we draw the queen
onto a vulnerable square and then guys
i everything is under control did you
not see me play min
with full due respect as i know what i'm
doing um queen takes f3 f takes c4 and
we counter attack
white's queen so if he takes our queen
and we take his queen with a rook
this line is not that hard to calculate
it's just a bit hard to see the move
knight takes f3
because it's not very intuitive to give
up the strong knight but you remember
that
uh tactics transcends any kind of
general considerations when you can win
a piece
for no compensation you want to do that
over and above preserving a piece on a
good square
i know but people get nervous and i
don't want people to get nervous
because you know i know it might seem
annoying that i'm sort of waiting it out
but i'm
i know how much time i need to win a
position like this
okay king h1 so again we don't need to
panic here all we need to do is move our
queen we need to figure out
where we want to put our queen such that
uh we
disallow any freak threats from him and
again in the interest of time i'm just
gonna play the move queen back to d8
uh if he takes our knight then we take
his knight and the game is over
if he doesn't do that then okay that's a
that's an empty check that doesn't do
anything
and now we're attacking his rook we're
attacking his knight and uh we're just
gonna take his rook
now we're gonna take his pawn and uh
that's it we are up a rook in an end
game i'm gonna play a little bit fast
here
just to um yeah so he resigns because
the game is over that was a nice game i
mean that was a
only a 27 move game but it was very rich
and thank you not a rapper it was very
rich
okay so it was a c uh a c3 sitalian it
was a c3 cetillion
oops sorry we're just checking okay it
was a c3 sicilian and we played the move
d5 which is one of the two main lines
does anybody remember what the other
main line is
what is the other main line in this
position
the other main line is of course knight
to f6 yeah striking
the pawn on e4 it's the same idea right
we are trying to
prevent white from going d4 uncontested
but here we decided on d5 okay so d4
knight c6 knight f3 bishop g4
um e6 is is normal right
uh h3 bishop h5 i actually think bishop
f5 might be
a better move i'm not exactly sure and
here he goes c4
okay so um it's important here to choose
the right square for the queen
if we go queen e4 the queen gets tangled
up white goes knight c3 this is out of
the question
why not take the knight after hd so we
talked about something pretty similar a
while ago
um which is that a lot of people would
look at this position and say wait a
second we can take the pawn
and now we can win a pawn we can we can
take the knight and isn't that the whole
point of what we're trying
to do but did somebody remind me what
the flaw is in this
in this uh reasoning and if you guys
remember i showed you a game from
my own chess career where i was able to
exploit a similar idea
bishop takes knight check it's very
simple and now the queen is lost
so you want to be careful about putting
all your eggs in one basket
this bishop is super valuable you do not
want to give white's bishop
this monster diagonal if that makes
sense
okay so that's why we did this so queen
d7 is is a very circumspect move
that queen is is doing the most that it
can be doing
and really one of the early critical
moments occurs after d5 why not d6 well
that blocks the bishop
the main reason i didn't want to put the
queen here is because later i thought
maybe i can develop the bishop somewhere
i didn't want to um didn't want to
commit
to e7 okay jerry bomb thank you for the
for the two months okay so hopefully
that makes sense so
d5 this is the critical moment
um and the reality is
black is in trouble if we don't have
this move this is the only move actually
that i believe that doesn't lose the
game
because let's assume that knight d8 for
example
is played if you just look at black's
position i mean white can just
pile up in many different ways so for
example g4
and the idea of g4 is to free up one of
white's other pieces could somebody now
tell me
how do you nurture the initiative this
is a very natural move centralizing one
of white's pieces
and this wins the game never more or
less thank you for the prime knight e5
this forces the queen to let's say c7
and now another devastating shot
all across all across the board
fireworks are happening and white is
having all of the fun
well bishop f4 is good but you can make
another move first you can give a check
on a4
and just look at this white black cannot
cover this check at all you have to move
move the king bishop f4 discovery the
game is over it's like plus
10 according to the computer so for
example
queen b6 check checkmate on g5 that's
one option
so you guys can see how bad this can
become and so
you need to identify these kinds of
moments in the game you need to identify
moments
when you feel like okay i need to find
an only move i need to find an accurate
move in order not to lose and then you
need to hunker down
really hunker down and and just search
for it
be stubborn and here i i was stubborn in
the sense that i don't want to move my
knight to d
i want my knight on d4 how can i get it
there well
the knight on f3 is uh preventing the
move knight e4 from being a thing
because black loses actually just a
piece not even a pawn but a piece
because the bishop on h5 is now lost
does that make sense if you take on e2
then knight takes
e2 and so uh we can't forget about our
bishop on h5 we take the knight
and we guarantee ourselves this very
nice outpost the position becomes
highly unclear okay so knight c3
are there telltale signs well largely
it's instinctive but there are telltale
stones i mean look at the position just
visually right
it looks like white's developing a big
initiative i mean he's tempo tempo tempo
our king is in the center those are the
telltale signs it just appears that if
i'm not careful i might just get blown
off the board
that's largely an instinctive thing but
it is an instinctive thing because there
are telltale signs
so that's one way of identifying
critical moments just like things feel
things feel very wrong it feels like
things are about to go very wrong
particularly in relation to your king
i can't give you guys anything more
specific because there are no
formulaic sort of methods of determining
a critical moment
and that's why you train right kelma
see i'm thank you for the tier one okay
whoops
sorry did not mean to do that bishop
takes f3 knight d4
now we of course develop our knight and
now bishop e3 we cement the knight with
e5
this is another very important move very
important move
now um does it make sense to you guys
why we don't want to take the bishop why
didn't he trade off yeah i'll explain
that in a second so we don't take the
bishop because this knight
is our strongest piece um the night is
like
what would i compare it to let me think
of a good analogy give me a second guys
actually let me grab some water
and as i'm grabbing water i'm going to
think of the best analogy to describe
the situation
hashtag dedicated teacher just um one
second
so i came up with the idea of a dam
you know like an aswan high dam in egypt
or the hoover dam
this night is like the dam if the night
is gone the water
floods your position white gets all of
these pieces in
and um as they say in russian you won't
even
be able to collect your bones at the end
that's how badly you'll get demolished
so the knight is like the uh you know
the keeper
of the of the position it keeps us away
from a big flood
and so we have to protect the knight
with e5 sorry for the violent comparison
but hey
um now you guys will remember okay so
castles
uh you can also say in russian a
slightly less violent expression
uh it literally translates to you will
not
carry away your legs which basically
means
uh yeah it basically means uh you will
not be able to escape right you won't
carry away your legs
but it's it's meant in a very emphatic
sense like even your legs will not be
able to carry you to safety like you're
basically busted
okay so e5 right now some of
some people um there are plenty of less
violent expressions but there's also
plenty of violent ones
a lot of people were asking why bishop
takes d4 is was not played and this was
possible
um and and which way do you guys think i
would have taken on d4 not an obvious
question by the way
which uh pawn should we take on d4 with
and what is the reason
uh for that um let's see what people
think so we have
people on both sides of the aisle here
which is always good
whoops sorry i did not mean to do that
um
okay so the correct move in my opinion
is actually sea takes
let's debate why do people want to take
with the e pawn
what's the rationale behind this
c takes d5 allows the pass pawn to
advance
keeps the king safe for chimpanzee are
you behind c takes d4 or he takes d4
cc okay so there is a specific reason
why i think this move is good
and the specific reason involves this
little piece over here
okay the diagonal for the bishop is
opened up so when the knight moves
hey this is a super nasty check
the king has to move and now we are the
ones who castle so the table's turned
white's king is the one
which is uh which is in danger and white
has no way to stop issue before
so um this will force white's king into
a relatively precarious position
but um you should also think about it
this way he takes d4
opens up that e file now who does the
e-file
who is the e-file likely to benefit well
it's likely to benefit the side
that is the first to castle because the
side that is the first two castle is
going to be the side that first is able
mathematically to put a rook on e1 and
the side that is faster to castle is of
course white because white is now ready
to castle and the next move
black still needs to develop a bishop
does that make sense so e takes d4
i think is fine it's not a huge deal but
for the higher rated among you
uh you know nuances like these are are
what
decide games you know so this shouldn't
be sneezed then
okay why is getting a rook on the file
for a spell because you control the open
file controlling open files is good
yeah castling long would be too
dangerous though if you castle along
i mean if you castle along here just if
you look at
where my cursor is around black's king i
mean
white can go before and he can blast
open the king position
it will take black a lot longer to do
the same thing to white's king because
white has significantly less weaknesses
on the king's side okay
so yeah e5 would would have also been
possible by the way so bishop d6
developing the bishop blockading the
pawn
rookie one castles a3 and here i would
have considered uh
h6 by the way to prevent bishop g5 but
we played a6 to prepare b5
bishop g5 and now knight e8 98 drops the
knight back
remember don't be afraid to make
retreating moves
and uh another reason this move is good
is because it opens up
the path for the f-pawn so this idea of
going f5 e4 comes to mind
we actually won the game with this idea
knight e4
dropping the bishop back to e7 basically
kind of regrouping our pieces the knight
from f6
maneuvers over to d6 and the bishop
drops back to e7 in order to lighten the
load by
effectuating a trade okay so bishop
takes e7
queen takes c7 already white is worse
this is probably a mistake i think that
not a rapper should have maybe retreated
back to e3 and kept the pieces on the
board
because very quickly uh i'm able to just
wipe white's pieces off of the board
why couldn't white play before to attack
your pawn chain
in which position well maybe he could
have maybe he actually should have
played before
yeah b4 might have been possible because
after cb
a b uh bishop takes before you can play
bishop takes d4
and material equality has been restored
white gets a slightly more free position
although here black is still fine rook
ac8 to attack the pawn on c4
why drop the bishop back when knight
takes d6 knight takes d66 makes your
knight a blockade or anyway that's a
good question
so why are we making this move if i just
claimed that the knight is the best
blockader
um well there's a couple of reasons
right
um first of all i want to eliminate
white's dark squared bishop specifically
i want to eliminate white star square
bishop specifically and the reason why
is that let's say you make the move b5
uh first of all
notice that the e5 pawn is hanging
although it may be possible to respond
with the move f6 forking the rook and
the bishop i actually didn't see that uh
this is pretty calculating pretty far so
no it would have been possible to go b5
but i thought that this bishop is a bit
of a loose cannon and so i figured
if i'm already going to give up the
bishop i might as well
take out an important piece with it
thank you i'm a black belt for the prime
i have five chasing away the knight and
uh
this move works only because of the
tactic that ensued in the game now if
the knight moves away
then we go knight d6 and then we go e4
and then we can prepare f4
and uh we have just an amazing position
here all of our pieces
are in the game after rookie e8 so this
is just crushing
so uh d6 right and this is less
mysterious than it appears the point is
that you uh
you you try to open up the position and
after knight takes d6
the knight no longer has the d5 pawn
kind of as an umbrella i call that upon
an umbrella pawn
without that umbrella pawn that bishop
can actually slam itself into d5
the position becomes super unclear here
okay
and knight takes f3 check is what wins a
piece knight takes f3
he plays king h1 now if queen takes f3
who can remind me of black's move
who can remind me of black's move
and why does it work f takes e4
f takes e4 and we counter attack the
queen but the important part is that we
attack the queen with a rook
if we take the queen of the pawn then we
drop the rook on f8
it's crucial that in taking with the
f-pawn
our rook actually makes contact with the
queen
and if white tries to desperado
sacrifice his queen then we take the
queen with our queen so none of it works
black is
white is going to be down a piece so
uh in the game he played king h1 trying
to trick me but now we just drop our
queen back and
you know this is all a paper tiger it's
water under the bridge
because oops sorry keep pressing the
wrong button because we're just up a
rook and there's nothing to be afraid of
remember that when you're up this much
material you can basically
give up some of that material i made
this point as early as game one of the
speed run
like that's one of the most fundamental
principles of of
uh converting an advantage when you've
got a lot of extra material you can give
some of it away
in order to simplify your task do not be
afraid don't take that too far
but do not be afraid to sacrifice a pawn
or two
in order to clear the cobwebs so nothing
like
insane in this game right nothing that i
did was like out of the realm of the
ordinary
uh it was certainly a very interesting
game it was an interesting opening
the critical moment was really here
right we set the tone by putting the
knight on d4 that night on d4 won us the
game in the end
okay any questions
[Music]
you